[Music]
you went to music school as well you're
a big bake you're a big but one of those
basement yes I'm a bass I slab at the
base I went to Berklee College of waste
your money music embossed them because
when I was 18 years old society was like
what do you want to do with your life
and I was like play bass lines man and
then you know four years later my
college was like awesome that'll be a
hundred
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Okin I can't say the f-word they'll
believe it you can yeah ôhe double hog
he said I spilled self-conscious because
your your family is this your family
I feel like Pete's parents come to every
show you'd think they are in town are
they and I can feel it really why don't
you invite them to the show yeah cuz you
were the guest they'll be mrs. Holmes
nice to meet you surprisingly might
matter it doesn't matter relax she's a
big clench your buttcheeks we get me off
though every bad word since we were five
been to summer camp or prison are you oh
god I ever hear well this interview just
went off the brass I feel like we're on
mushrooms when's the last time you did
mushrooms Oh 2025 minutes ago
[Laughter]
I thought we were in my living room
oh my god wouldn't I get all these
cameras and you run into somebody sober
the whole thing you're thinking is just
like you with me or against me just
ultimately are you on my side or your
that's what I really need to know at the
bottom of all I am in the fifth
dimension I have like Google Earth view
in my eyeballs right now by you with
pins to all the Starbucks
I hate Sponge Bob Squarepants acid at
Bonnaroo this year and it was like
Google Earth it was like the spy was on
Planet Zebulon that was on Planet
Zebulon they put cartoon children's
cartoons on the acid now what kind of
ren and stimpy acid spongebob acid you
got it oh you don't have to know
[Music]